I imagine for a moment having to undergo
any of the following your nails plucked
out being hung upside down electrocuted
in your private parts stripped naked
these are just some of the 31 types of
torture human rights groups allege are
being employed by indian security forces
in the disputed region of Jammu and
Kashmir located in the north of India
the entire state is claimed by both
Pakistan and India long-running
resentment against Indian rule led to a
full-blown insurgency in the late 80s
that brought with it a heavy presence of
Indian troops now a report by two NGOs
the association of parents of
disappeared persons and the Jammu
Kashmir coalition of civil society says
the government has been using torture
against the local population
indiscriminately since 1947 and that for
the most part the abuses are going
unpunished a professor Niels Meltzer is
the UN Special Rapporteur on torture and
he joins me now from Geneva professor
Meltzer glad you could join us
now these allegations aren't new these
allegations of torture have been made
against the Indian government before
does this report change anything
obviously are very very serious and
suggest that there might be very grave
violations of the prohibition of torture
now I'm not in a position to assert the
accuracy of all these allegations but I
unfortunately was not and to visit India
myself despite several requests to
conduct an official visit what is it
that the Indian government says every
time you bring up this request that you
want to visit India and my understanding
is that no UN Special Rapporteur on
torture has never been able to visit
India to verify any such claims
unfortunately despite several requests
an official request submitted to the
Indian government I have not received
any response so far now India is also
signatory to the United Nations
Convention Against Torture but it hasn't
yet been ratified is there a way for the
international community to pressure
India to ratifying this convention so
that India can be held accountable under
this convention international legal
instrument really is in the sovereign
decision of the concern state so no
state can be forced to ratify a treaty
however the prohibition of torture is
not dependent on the ratification of a
treaty because it is considered to be
the fundamental customary human right
which is even in curry which means it
cannot even be ignored or changed
through a separate treaty so it is one
of the strongest customary human rights
that is recognized universally one of
the strongest customary human rights as
you put it yet we keep getting report
off the report which accuses the Indian
government of using torture in Jammu and
Kashmir how can change be brought about
unfortunately regular allegations of
torture treatment and the the experience
shows however that real change is always
brought about from within the country
through public opinion through a public
pressure through reform Indian
institutions and in the policies of the
state it is also important to understand
that torture is an ineffective tool of
providing security or finding the truth
in criminal investigations it really is
a tool to break people to intimidate
people that destroys not only the victim
but also the perpetrators and in the end
the dehumanizes even the society itself
that tolerates such abuse so in a sense
torture is counterproductive but
States do not seem to understand that
and yet persist with that practice
unfortunately it takes a long time for
the consciousness and do you understand
me to come through of how destructive
torture really is again I cannot assert
to what exactly the facts are in India
because I have not been able to to
investigative myself right I have
received I lose myself as well
Niels Meltzer the UN Special Rapporteur
on torture thank you very much for
speaking to DW News Asia